Sam where were you on sep tember 11 2001
mm-hmm well I was there I was still
working as an engineer which is uh
people might not know but I'm an
engineer by profession and filmmaker by
choice and and I remember I was you know
I was sitting my desk and and I heard
somebody walked into my you know to my
room in San was like did you hear what
just happened it's right on TV and we
had a TV in an hour you know one of the
offices so we all ran over there and I
was in a witness single actually witness
the second plane hitting that you know
the second tower on TV in definitely it
was you know everybody was panicking and
was you know it was something that I
experienced but I think I always I
always try to stay positive and the way
I reacted to 911 is by switching from
being an engineer to being a filmmaker
to tell a story to tell people
what we thought and what I thought
myself about 911 and how I would I
reacted to it and and i felt i will
never i don't want to look back I'm
gonna look just forward and see what i
can do for this country and what I can
you know help is like Abraham in the
movie and I thought thats this is the
only way this is the only way to to
basically make the human connection in
and to connect with people and to be
successful and and and to help others
and I think the citizen is really it is
a payoff is it is a I mean it is a
message of really love to to America and
to the Arab world I think to both I
tried to put this in a movie and you
know in an entertaining way not in a
boring way an entertaining way with just
what there is a story and you feel
you're attached to the character is in
everything and the movie is it inspired
by two events it's not just 911 but most
of the events in and most of the stories
in in the citizen happened for real so I
thought I want to share these stories
with you guys so so you can feel what a
lot of people in a lot of Arabs and a
lot of immigrants in general I mean it's
not just about Arabs but a lot of
immigrants felt around that time so this
is you know where i was before nine
eleven and this is what I are where I am
right now and I try to make something I
try to move forward and I would like
everybody to look forward how do you
think that people have changed since
nine eleven do you think other people
are in a similar boat where they are
questioning where their life path is
going and they say I want to do what
really moves me instead of maybe have a
stable job that you know is the right
sort of path but maybe doesn't fulfill
me inside how do you think we've changed
well you know let me let me take it to
this this lady who we had a sneak-peek
preview on Colorado
Collins and we had you know we have like
almost 600 people came for this we pay
per view which was great and there was
this lady she's about like 60 65 years
old who waited about I would say about
20 minutes until they cleared stage and
we cleared stage and now we have to
leave the theater and she was waiting
just to say one thing and I remember she
told me Sam thank you so much because
you brought this feeling that I lost 20
years ago about Who I am and what I can
do and what this country is all about
and I think movie do not really change
the world but people who see these
movies can and this is what we're trying
to do you know you know I'm not really
responsible for people who they haven't
changed or they will never change or
they would never you know think any
different I mean I always try to look
you know for for for the second half of
the cup the empty you know have and try
just to push forward and do things right
so everybody will follow you so this is
this is kind of like my my my theory you
know I don't want to say people have
changed or they have not changed it's up
to them if they change or they or they
don't change I do things right and I
think everybody will look at you and
think of you as it as a role model and
they started doing what you you are the
good is you laid by a good example and
this is what we're trying to do
you